adeus à champions jogando muito mal a
minha mão como quem pessoalmente a briga
não é disso que vamos aparecer no fim
mais mas sim aproximava fica bem meu
papel era de reina e amor vestiu neves
morreu hebe isso não precisa jogar não
né e não precisa ser bom não precisa já
que são mais da relação ao meu voto meu
deus
o meia jean antoninho não participei fui
eu e não pega pega out to adeus à
champions
eu também em breve ele estará pronto a
festa deste ano
estamos em um jogo de dois japoneses não
mudarei meu ainda olha só que aí
conseguir os nossos vídeos e fica vai se
eu que ganho das pocinhas pode comer
aqui como assim
qualquer jovem de entrar agora no avião
então eu voltei a jogar estou toda hora
tudo de bola que vai nos tirar pois
dólares gol foi muito cansativo muito
doente mesmo e agora vai ser o primeiro
contato tem que correr genérico ver como
é que a cidade lá fora vai ser longo e
curto é aquela montanha lei e eu estava
olhando para ela cantar memory por cá
muito lembra o que acho que o quartel e
vamos lá me vejam só esta câmera meu é
muito grande esta cama rock in rio 2017
press antónio ramos luta livre que uma
caixinha que isto rock no rio vibrio e é
muito louco ocorre no rio para baixo
este é o seu ingresso vip insistem em 16
de setembro de 7 anos de estudo
eu acho muito louco a serem muitas
costas ainda são seis da manhã e já
havia apreendido em mente mas é o quarto
é muito louco olha só é muito grande
muito fácil e tem 10 mar e olha aí nas
paredes do que comida comida etapa
induziu bem vazio em padre roque para
arrumar a roupa a mocinha de janela e
dinélson deve ter uma pista button
o olha só meu isto aqui é muito
diferente em portugal a sério é muito
diferentes mas esta paisagem não é a
única coisa que o governo é porque algum
desses planos de visitar muita coisa vou
passar pelo cope mil internos mostrará
tudo e aí eu não posso deixar as quatro
ateus em implementar a câmera é fez 21
vai
é muito gostoso kun daqui só está a ser
muito rápido estava cheio muito rápido
será que vai abrir ó
o lance muito bom a isso um lancia como
assim é muito gostoso jogando daquele
bem fechou por aí sim eu nem tinha 60
anos - paulista o rock in rio ainda
vazio né win não vou saltar em andamento
o hawks que sofrem andamento ea taxa que
eles tinham que sair eu gastarei ajudar
cada aposentado joão almeida ba e
magnitude do espanhol com isso a do
brasil no youtube mas não estar aqui à
nossa espera
meu antigo logo olha só o roda gigante
para isso usa a mesma frente do farol e
montanha vamos aqui vamos direto para
montanhas logo logo logo vou deixar pra
lá embora já anda janela é melhor do que
o nosso
amigo acontecer isso
ninguém passa lá em cima do jobson sua
montanha russa é muito grande
olha aí muito grande é um pouquinho só
tem um gato em cima de mim
a lei ainda não foi o único a ver comigo
o que também veio eu estava em cima
procura camila viana capa vasp
op lá eu to aqui trancada na copinha lá
o que acho que essa taxa de jovens
machos mas não só isso é muito muito
muito muito muito muito ainda vai ter lá
em cima muito muito muito grande é muito
grave
saiba também o que é um dos grandes
alvos
[Aplausos]
só tô aqui no rock in rio até o primeiro
dia como pode ver o que o fundo eu não
sei quem está lá mas tem uma hora em
cantar mal essa pessoa entrou em palco
que o encheu com muita gente mesmo que o
pessoal tava que tudo foi do brasil e
dentro de muitas comidas melhor general
chefe carlos sombra não era uma maneira
muito aguda tem um som muito ainda pra
mim pois não só é muito bem ontem um
site que vai desde o wii até aqui e
deixei o estudo
ora eu to town uma pessoa chega aqui uma
pessoa 32 um pai é uma pizza bar maria
muito estranho assim mas é melhor
é muito melhor sem nada fazer que alguns
históricos do rock no rio apesar de não
estar a funcionar porque thomsen neto
mas estamos a fazer muita história e
portanto chegou e se não se consigam
roubar frame que vamos ter que provar e
do rock in rio que por aí sim o de
cantor não tem nada que nós não
conseguimos internet mas não temos no
brasil com mais 60 anos no brasil
é muita montanha bonita meu eu to de
futebol português
bom pessoal conta que o hotel porque o
menino foi tomar banho e também vim
apanhar neto por lá no meio do caminho e
eu fiquei sem meta e vocês já sabem que
o bc neto no youtube
então eu vim aqui pra postar mais forte
nem se fazer um dia histórico e vou
aproveitar para descansar um pouco né
só que um jeito bem escrevem que não
rende na equipe e não sair então estava
conhecer algum jeito moleque do rio
só que eu não sei você está vendo algum
em outubro que vive aqui perto rio que
deixe nos comentários porque sim
possível conhecer um não é porque o quer
muito interagir com o pessoal aqui do
brasil e quero também interagir com
vocês os meus fãs que pode ser que venha
fazer alguns vídeos com ela sou assim
que passei lá eu só quero divertir e
fazer que os bichos e pessoal 8 que no
12º andar aqui do hotel hilton de imensa
gente limpa só espera que a janela vocês
vão ver continuar pessoas que ainda
tentam entrar no rock in rio nesta ponte
toda aqui tem muita gente mas não soube
parecem formigas está a ser muito louco
mesmo portanto acompanhe os próximos
vídeos porque vou mostrar muito mais
coisas vão andar de montanha russa vão
andar na roda gigante e vão dar muita
coisa radical dentro do cockpit não
perco eu acho assim o tipo a lojas
pronto
nash pronto a
bom como está o o vejam só tá muita
gente o meu deus tem doces de salgadinho
e eu quero já tinha um homem sombra
não sei só se conhece um homem sombra
menu é o homem sombra ou está muito em
quadrado aqui não pode faltar muito
quadrado
[Música]
hoje não só continua a sua stack
muita gente ruim o que nós vamos ver
agora um jovem samba meu tio luciano que
tenhamos medo
o conflito foi o que quer dizer que a
campanha não viu em campo mas fora do
evento
agora vergonha agora como é que está
dito jolie não em rolim está orinoco em
diante ele não fugir às necessidades
vitais como écran fran conversou comigo
muito lucro eo mais engraçado é que eu
não sei cantar cantar e também não sei
quem irá cantar mas eu tenho um caminhão
na mina san josé está esse cabelo não
tem cabeça olhar franco encontrou o
fecho allen só olha amigo prefeito roque
está pensando pobre vai rolar em
tratamento do brasil 22 da equipe
solares tipo ai ai e joão perturbar no
banho daquela escola começa a colar
todos os jogos é quem falar tão fácil
graça que o grupo corre muito e são
muito bem vindas mas o novo nem fácil
o frio vai dar problema agora vai dar
mais mais mais mais mais
atacou sol eu querer e eu quero ir
é fila eu não vou não está muita gente
olha nós temos nada que me convidou o
fundador da motown e vejam só eu não
critico o ou vai muito rápida muita
gente
[Música]
andar em baixa enquanto a equipa
olá pessoal entretanto a noite acabou eu
fiquei sem bateria pois nós vamos para o
hotel e ainda fiquei acordado editar o
vídeo agora de manhã do dia eu ainda não
dormir então tô aqui fazer este final do
vídeo porque não consegui fazer na hora
quando cheguei ao hotel mas estou
gostando muito é uma experiência muito
louca que o rock in rio está aqui no
brasil é muito bom é isso é só me
escondi aqui portanto ainda vou ficar
aqui muito tempo e espero que seja tão
divertido como trazendo até agora e
agora vou ter que preparar vou ter que
tomar banho e tenho que me preparar pra
gravar um novo hub hoje e por estar
amanhã mas é isso aumentem o que é que
vocês não acharam então estava sendo
este um vídeo eu espero mesmo que vocês
tenham gostado porque toma divertir
muito mesmo muito já está bem pessoal
deixem muito líquido neste vídeo mesmo
ter muito líquido neste vídeo e é isso
fiquem bem e até a próxima